[musique]
Et
essentiellement m'a invité dans ses rangs
parti Vladimir Zelenki
nous nous connaissions avant et apparemment
il a considéré ces qualités pour moi
ce qui vous permet de contribuer
développement du sport ukrainien
[musique]
clarté
100% des Ukrainiens ne sont pas nés ici
et pourtant après la perte de la vie dans laquelle je vis
L’Ukraine elle-même l’a défendu, au moins
il y a beaucoup d'offres avec lui
citoyenneté et jouer pour une autre équipe et
puis des litres similaires mais néanmoins je
il y a toujours eu quelqu'un dans ce pays et et
je savais que tôt ou tard
Boer pour un changement positif
[musique]
[applaudissements]